je suis très difficile de d'exprimer en
français hein si on m'a laissé à écrire
je peux je peux écrire 200 pages ou bien
300 pages tous meses sentiments mes
expressions à la
mes
les les paparies de
PO demain donc vous suivrez ce reportage
fort émouvant dans question de temps à
21h30 présenté par Louis Berriot s' est
un domaine où les Français se
distinguent c'est celui de l'astronomie
les scientifiques français sont réputés
dans le monde entier alors que pourtant
notre pays est plutôt mal placé sur le
globe les nuits sans nuag sont peu
nombreuses chez nous surtout depuis
quelques temps or nous pensions avoir
trouvé enord de grâce dans les altes
maritimes le site édéal et voici que la
pureté du ciel y est menacée Laurent
bromhead s'est rendu sur place pour
enquêter pour observer les étoiles il
faut un ciel pur des nuit sans nuage
mais aussi de gros télescopes qui
coûtent très cher ces conditions sont
réunies sur le plateau de calerne
choisie en 1970 pour abriter le Centre
d'études et de recherchees géodynamique
et astronomique le Serga qui a nécessité
un investissement de 20 millions de
francs mais à peine les astronomes
ont-ils eu le temps d'installer leurs
puissants appareils qu'ils s'inquiètent
une carrière située à 7 km à vol
d'oiseau envisage de multiplier sa
production un million de tonnes par an
de gravier extrait de la montagne des
tonnes de poussières propulsées dans
l'atmosphère cette carrière est située
exactement sous le vent dominant lorsque
le temps est très beau ici ce qui fait
que pendant la journée les poussières
extraites par la carrière vont traverser
le plateau où on se trouve et la nuit au
moment o la température change l'air
froid redescend de la montagne et se
stabilise juste auudessus du plateau
c'est juste entre le télescope et les
étoiles alors cétait un avantage cette
stabilisation de l'air c'est c'est pour
ça que le site a été choisi c'est qu'on
a une très très grande stabilité du ciel
ici de l'atmosphère ici fait que les
images ne bougent absolument pas
l'avantage devient ici un inconvénient
et les astronomes se lamentent comme
l'inventeur de ce téléscope
révolutionnaire Antoine Laber alors
quels sont vos
problèmes il a un problème de poussière
ça c'est catastrophique les poussières
qui partent de la carrière illuminent le
ciel sont éclairé par les lampes de la
côte éclair le ciel
et reti une grande partie de ce qu'on
pourrait voir sur les photographies
faites avec les télescopes qui sont ici
alors ensuite il y a le problème des des
vibration n'est-ce pas nous l'instrument
que nous avons ici est du d'une
sensibilité absolument effarante il peut
détecter des déplacements du sol d'un
milliè de millimè il suffit d'un camion
qui passe à 10 km pour perturber ses
observations alors vous imaginez avec le
le le charois de camion gigantesque les
millions de tonnes de blocs qui vont
passer là si ça va plus être possible
d'observer pourtant il faut absolument
des pierres pour les chantiers du
département et seule la carrière de
Gourdon convient mais que se
passerait-il si le ciel de calerne
devait un jour
s'obscurcir à ce momentl je crois que il
faudra que qu'on parte ailleurs le
gouvernement fait un très gros
investissement
ici mais tant pis on peut pas persister
plusieurs mois seront sans doute
nécessaires aux autorités pour faire le
choix délicat entre les pierres et les
étoiles nous continuons à parler
d'étoile i Comar c'est le nom du film
que tourne actuellement Yv monan surous
la direction d'hanry verneil un film
coproduit par la SFP et Antenne 2 il
raconte l'histoire d'un attentat contre
un chef d'État et aborde le problème de
l'obéissance à une autorité supérieure
c'est plus qu'un film policier a
expliqué Yve Montan à gerérard Holz
pendant
tournage cheveux blancs lunettes costume
strict Yve montant s'est volontairement
donner cette allure quelque peu sévère
pour mieux entrer dans la peau de son
personnage y montant dans iicar c'est le
procureur
[Musique]
volenet un magistrat qui enquête sur
l'attentat contre un chef d'État qui va
rejeter les conclusions de la commission
officielle chargée de l'affaire et
surtout un magistrat qui va poursuivre
ses investigations jusqu'au vrais
coupable l'attentat contre le président
contre un président c'est surtout ce que
j'appellerai le support du film le film
départ comme ça c'est ce qui se passe
par la suite qui m'a intéressé
l'assassinat du président m'intéresse la
manière dont ça pu être fait car on
naffirme rien et ce qui m'intéresse
c'est surtout la manipulation et aussi
la soumission à l'autorité qui est tiré
d'un livre de tant les 1000 grames où
l'on voit comment un homme
un homme disons un homme ordinaire un
homme extrêmement gentil un homme de
tous les jours peut arriver à des choses
monstrueuses du moment qu'il est couvert
par par l'autorité ce que nous avons
entendu du reste durant le le procès de
nurberg entre autres et d'autes procès
de ce genre hen Verne dit que c'est un
film policier à 100 % vous êtes d'accord
avec
lui oui je dirais que c'est si ça avait
été qu'un seul F policier je l'Auris
peut-être pas fait non pas que je
policiainant
mais c'est parce que ça beaucoup plus
loin sans que ce soit vous voulez
mangmatique mais bien au contraire
découvrir quelque chose et à travers les
interpr découvrose qu'on j montr àécran
c'est ça qui m'a intéressé c'est des
raisons pour lesqu j'ai travé
avecalement parce que ce de film
précisément si ce n'est pas qu'un film
policier ver les épaules assez solid il
le talent pour donner justement ce genre
de cinéma à
l'américaine qui peut devenir un film de
résonance internationale c'est la raison
pour laquel j'ai fait ce film pour
l'instant vous n'êtes pas payé non je ne
suis pas payé je fais ce film en tant
que coproducteur
avec verneil enfin il est beaucoup plus
producteur que moi moi en fait je suis
si vous voulez son associé et c'est bien
agréable aussi de travailler comme ça
parce que c'est une partie de poker si
le film marche mais ça c'est secondaire
pour moi je vous dis tout de suite non
pas du tout que je sois désintéressé que
l'argent ne m'intéresse pas c'est pas ça
il nous en faut il en faut tout le monde
mais je veux dire par là que ce qui
m'intéresse le plus c'est l'histoire si
si le film fait de l'argent et bien
bravo s'il n'en fait pas parfait je
comprends très bien qu'on puisse faire
des productions et qu'on fasse du cinéma
de cette façon
aujourd'hui en ce jour de la fête des
mère chacun de nous a offert ce qu'il a
pu à sa mère s'il a la chance de l'avoir
encore ou à la mère de ses enfants
quelquefois nous nous sommes demander
quel cadeau offrir et bien notre
correspondant permanent aux États-Unis
Jacques séy vous présente un appareil
que toutes les mères et toutes les
femmes aimeraient posséder un robot qui
fait tout ENF presque tout et qui évite
à ceux ou à celles qui le possèdent tout
travail et j'espère tout
[Musique]
souci R2 D2 le héros du film La Guerre
des étoiles avait décidé ce jour là de
faire une petite promenade en forêt dans
la bonlieue de Chicago il n'y avait que
lui pour nous donner une bonne
la maison de Monsieur ben un célibataire
qui V avec un copain de R2 D2 le robot
[Musique]
à bienvenue messieurs dans la maison de
haroc le
robot monsieur scora passe sa vie dans
son
fauteuil voilà j'ouvre mon
bar et puis maintenant je le
ferme et puis maintenant je pourrais
peut-être faire entrer un peu plus de
lumière dans ce salon en ouvrant ces
rideauxis vous allez voir je peux les
refermer fait tout ça en appuyant
simplement sur un
bouton comme pour cette
lampe ah voilà le téléphone qui sonne et
bien je va répondre d'ici
oui
allô c'est Antenne 2 la télévision
française à
Washington
voici comment allezv je suis très
heureux de vous
rencontrer
et les effusions allaient être longues
et la poignée de main
ferme tout marche ici à l'électronique
dit Monsieur benscora alors que nous
étions passés au livg près de la
fontaine mais regardez bien ce qui va
suivre l'eau coule dans la fontaine et
sans quitter notre fauteuil nous allons
faire un petit tour sur la
terrasse c'est à cet instant que
Monsieur Scor m'a dit qu'il était très
attaché à rooc ils se connaissent depuis
7 ans auparavant monsieur Scor
pratiquait la psychothérapie pour les
alcooliques les drogués des gens
malheureux mais aujourd'hui avec aroc il
a laissé tomber tout
çaoc parfois va faire quelques escapades
les foirosition par exemple pour gagner
sa vie à 800 dollars par
[Musique]
jour
à comme les anges n'a pas de sexe et
c'est sans doute pourquoi c'est lui qui
passe
l'aspirateur mais je vous l'ai ditur
SCOR s'entendent très bien le robot ne
fait pas tout le travail rebutant il y a
l'électronique passons rapidement dans
la chambre à coucher de Monsieur Scor et
vous allez voir que Monsieur Scor qui
aime l'électronique les robots et les
fleurs ne néglige aucun
détail
le goût pourtant très sûr de Monsieur SC
agace parfois et pour éviter tout scè de
ménage il va se promener alors avec le
chien Benj c'est seulement dans ce cas
que Monsieur SC vend la mèche qui vous a
fait robot rappil et sans moi qui
seriezv monsieur SC assis dans son
fauteuil mais il arrive qu'à roc parfois
se fâche le jour de notre visite par
exemple il voulait rejoindre son copain
R2 D2 que nous avons croisé au début de
cette histoire mais R2 D2 avait
disparu rugby la finale du championnat
de France de rugby n'a pas tenu ce
qu'elle promettait on attendait un match
passionnant pétillant entre le rugby
solide et puissant de Narbonne et la
cavalerie légère de banère en réalité ce
ne fut pas le cas et même loin de là ce
fut une mauvaise finale mais aussi une
finale méchante les avants ne cessant de
se donner des coups en douce résultat de
blessés un de chaque côté et deux exclus
un de chaque côté pas de jaloux en fait
il y eu peu de rugby cet après-midi au
parc Narbon a marqué ses 10 points en
première mi-temps deux pénalités de Parè
au 22e et 26e minute et un essai à la
30e minute mais est ouverte par qui va
croiser avec CODOR codorn qui s'arrache
à la défense de bannière passe à tralero
l'essai marqué par tralero ne sera pas
transformé victoire de Narbon 10 à 0 un
match à
oublié dernière réunion à Longchamp
avant le Grand Prix de Paris le tiercé a
vu un doublé des chevaux entraînés par
Bernard SELI qui ont pris les deux
premières places SELI surnommé par les
turfistes et nos confrères de la presse
épique monsieur thiercé a une fois de
plus justifié ce surnom nous allons
prendre le Ploton juste en bas de la
descente alors qu'il y a eu regroupement
au centre un cheval au naasau blanc el
Conor récent vainqueur et qui est
attaqué par le 14 gr Castle un cheval à
robe grise qui va venir dans ce tournant
à
l'extérieur voici le moment voici
l'instant
Conor nazau blanc casac gris toque rouge
et l'autre qui l'attaque la dernière
ligne droite est assez courte il faut
partir à temps prince t kazac rose place
son effort suivi par le
4 verfoncé et au Pavillon ils vont se
détacher prinstead et nachites tandis
qu'à la corde la lutte pour la 3è place
et très sévère les parieur exul
prinstead le favori semble avoir pris un
avantage décisif nachites son camarade
d'entraînement ne peur rien contre lui
et le cheval de l'éclirie André Michel
gagne la course très nettement monté par
Freddy Head tandis que pour la trè place
Condor courageux va céder une tête à ble
dancing Master a bien couru d'ff a bien
terminé premier donc le 2e le 4 3e le 11
les rapports s'inscrivent sur votre
écran pour 5 francs
140250 et
2850 excusez-moi au Grand Prix de Monaco
victoire du Sud-Africain judis cheter
sur Ferrari devant razzoni Patrick de
paayet lui prend la 5e place au
classement du championnat du monde des
conducteurs checkter prend la tête avec
30 points devant la fit 24 points et de
payer 20 points le temps et bien ma fois
lundi demain sur la tier ouest le ciel
sera nuageux à couvert avec des pluies
et des averses les pluies seront plus
marqué de la vandé à la Bretagne et la
Normandie les vents d'ouest souffleront
par rafale sur la moitié est du pays
malgré quelques ondé matinales des
pérénées orientales aux Alpes et à la
Provence le temps sera assez bien
ensoleillé et les températures seront en
hausse je vous rappelle le dernier
journal Vers 2 3h15 présenté par AR
Claude demain le journal de la
mi-journée présenté par Patrick lecock
et et puis le journal de 20h ce dernier
je vous le rappelle sera transmis en
direct d'Athène présenté par Patrick
Poivre d'harbor et je présenterai
moi-même la partie qui sera diffusé de
Paris bonne soirée
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci